all right welcome everyone welcome back
let's get started we have another
action-packed day for you time's a
wasting
to start here I'm going to finish up our
big uh slide deck on contextual word
representations there are just a few
more small things to cover and then Sid
is going to get us help us get Hands-On
with training really big models
so there's the link as usual uh from the
website if you want to follow along and
we're going to skip right to this
section called Electro
Electra is a model that came from
Stanford from Kevin Clark and
collaborators and I think it's really
exciting it shows you the kind of design
space we're in a really creative example
of you know doing something that was
different from what had come before in
the space of Transformers
last time we talked about some known
limitations of the Bert model most of
them identified in the burp paper itself
I covered that first one you know we we
just wanted more ablation studies more
exploration of the bird architecture the
Roberta team kicked that off I think
they did a great job with Elektra we're
going to address known limitations two
and three the first is that we have a
mismatch between the train vocabulary
and the fine-tuned vocabulary because of
the role of the Mask token in training
Bert models and the second one which
might feel more pressing to you is that
Bert is pretty inefficient when it comes
to learning from data because we mask
out or replace about 15 percent of the
tokens and as you recall from The Bert
learning objective those are the only
tokens that contribute to the learning
objective itself all of the other work
is kind of redundant and so we might
hope that we could make more efficient
use of all these sequences that we're
processing elector is going to make some
progress on that too
so let's focus on the core model
structure and then we'll look at all the
other things they did in the paper
we'll start with our input sequence X
this is the chef cooked the meal
and the first thing we do is mask out
some of those tokens and that could be a
random sample of 15 of the tokens just
like in most work with Bert
then we have what could be literally a
Burt model we're going to call it the
generator typically a small one that has
a mass language modeling objective and
that can produce output sequences as
usual
however the twist here is that we're
going to replace some of the tokens that
came from the input with kind of
randomly sampled ones from the mlms you
can see here that we've copied over the
and copied over chef but now eight has
been replaced by cook that might not
have been the most probable output for
the model but we're going to do that
replacement step there so what we've
created Created here is a sequence that
we can call x-corrupt a corrupted
version of the input and that is the
primary job of this generator model
at this point the heart of Elektra takes
over this is called the discriminator
but we can also talk about it as the
electro model itself in essence the job
of the discriminator is to figure out
which of those tokens were originals and
which ones were Replacements so that's a
kind of contrastive learning objective
you can see here that the actual label
it's going to learn from from eight is
that it was replaced and for the that it
was an original even though it was a
sampled token and the actual loss for
the model is the generator that is the
typical Bert MLM loss together with this
electrol loss with a weighting
that's how the model is trained but
there is as I said in asymmetry here in
the sense that once we've done the
pre-training phase we can let the
generator Fall Away entirely and focus
just on the discriminator as the model
that we're going to use for Downstream
fine-tuning tasks and so you can see
already that we've in a way solved the
problem of having this weird mask token
that comes from the pre-training phase
because the discriminator never sees
Mass tokens all it sees are these
corrupted inputs and it learns to figure
out which ones are the corrupted
versions and which ones are the
originals
which is a different capability
intuitively than the one we were imbuing
the core Bert model with right so for
bird it's kind of like the objective is
to figure out what was missing from the
surrounding context and here it's like
trying to figure out which of the words
in the sequence doesn't belong and which
of them do belong a kind of more
discriminating objective
so that is Elektra
before we dive into the experiments and
stuff questions about how that model
works
yeah
it tries to predict which ones have been
replaced like do you use like what
applications do you use electric for
before pre-training yeah that's what you
got to get your head around this is a
great subtlety to bring out so the
discriminator is now going to be our
pre-trained artifact so just the way you
download Bert and when you do that
you're downloading some mln trained
object thing now you download Electra
which is the discriminator and it's been
trained to do this distinguishing thing
as opposed to the filling in the blank
or continuing thing from the models
we've seen so far the eye-opening thing
is that that contrastive objective leads
to a really good pre-trained state for
fine tuning
and we might hope that it's doing it
much more efficiently but that's what we
can dive into now here so
first a generator discriminator
relationships they observe in the paper
that when the generator and the
discriminator are the same size they can
share all their Transformer parameters
and more sharing is better so already we
have an efficiency gain and that's kind
of intriguing that one in the same set
of Weights would be playing the role of
the MLM and the discriminator generator
discriminator
but they observe that they guess the get
the best results from having a generator
that is small compared to the
discriminator
and this plot kind of teases that out so
we've got our glue score along the
y-axis this will just be a measure of
system quality for them and along the
x-axis here we have generator size and
what they mean by that is the
dimensionality of the model in the Bert
sense so essentially the size of each
one of the layers
and if we zoom in for example on this
blue line the best performing model this
is where we have 768 as our
dimensionality for the discriminator and
768 for the generator
as we make the generator smaller all the
way down to 256 performance improves
and that's what we mean when we say
better to have a small generator and a
large discriminator and that kind of
u-shaped pattern is repeated across all
the different discriminator sizes
about how this model is working which is
the sense that you kind of want the
generator to be a little bit of a noisy
process so that the discriminator has
some interesting work to do
and by making the discriminator more
powerful I guess you're creating that
kind of opportunity
they also do a lot of work looking at
efficiency because one of the side goals
of the elector paper was to end up with
models that were overall more efficient
in terms of the pre-training compute and
in terms of the model size here's
another way to quantify that again along
the y-axis we have the glue score and
along the x-axis now we have pre-trained
flops which you could just think of as a
very low level measure of how much
compute resources we need to do the
pre-training part
the blue line at the top is Elektra and
it's the best no matter what your
computational budget is along the x-axis
they also explore adversarial Electra
this is very intuitive to me that is a
slightly different objective where the
generator is trying to fool the
discriminator by creating corrupted
sequences that are hard for the
generator to distinguish
that's a really good model but it's less
than the kind of more Cooperative joint
objective that I showed you before
and then the green line is cool too so
the green line is where I start training
with Bert
and that at a certain point I switch to
having also the discriminator loss and
at that point The Bert model is less
good for any compute budget whereas the
Electoral variant starts to do its
electricity and get better and better
so a bunch of perspectives on Electra
all pointing to it being a good and
efficient model
and then finally they do a bunch more
efficiency analyzes so this is that
picture that I showed you of the full
Electro model before where I have the
generator creating corrupted sequences
and then the discriminator doing its
discriminating part there
you could also explore Elektra 15
percent and this is different from Full
Electra in the sense that on the right
for default Electra we make predictions
about all of these tokens whether they
were original or replaced for the 15
version we kind of do a burt-like thing
where we're going to assume that the
ones that weren't part of those
corrupted chains there the sampled part
are just not part of the objective it'll
be fewer tokens there
replace MLM this is an ablation where
actually we drop away the elector part
and we're just looking at the MLM here
and we're going to not have the mass
token at all
because remember for Bert there are a
few ways that they do this learning they
do the mass token and they also do the
one where they just replace it with some
random tokens here like cook to run and
then the model has to reproduce a new
token oh that should say cooked I guess
uh because it's pure Bert
uh
and this is a kind of look at what
happens if we don't introduce that mask
token of addressing that question about
whether that was disrupting learning and
then finally all tokens MLM this is
again just a Burt based objective over
here where instead of turning off the
objective for these ones here that
weren't part of the corrupted sequence
we do learning from all of them
and that's a way of saying for Bert if
we were making more efficient use of the
data could we learn more quickly
and here are the results so Electra is
at the top
but just below it is all tokens MLM so
that's just learning from all of the
tokens and I think that does show that
Bert could have been a little better if
they had not turned off the objective
for every single token that wasn't part
of the masking or corruption for that
learning process
replace MLM is just below that and
that's where we don't have any mask
tokens so there's no fine-tuning
pre-trained mismatch
Electra 15 below that and then Bert at
the bottom so overall you're seeing
these ablations are kind of showing us
that every piece of Electra is
contributing something to the overall
performance of the model and that's
quite nice as well
the efficiency yeah
well we're making more efficient use of
the data because we're getting a
learning signal from every token and I
guess that would be the important
Dimension because a funny thing about
Bert where we turn off the learning for
the ones that weren't Master corrupted
is that we still have to do the work of
computing them it's just that then they
don't become part of the objective and
here we're just kind of bringing that in
so for free or close to it
my question was how is the glue score
calculated what does it represent some
accuracy in language generation
afterwards or is it the classifier
that's being scored oh yeah so glue is a
big multitask classification Benchmark
it's a pretty diverse set of tasks maybe
biased toward natural language inference
and the reason they're using it in the
paper is just that it has been
it has been adopted as a kind of general
purpose measure of performance and it's
driven a lot of reasoning about what's
good and what's bad in the field
and then here are some model releases
Basin large kind of a line with Bert and
then we have this small model here and
that was designed to be quickly trained
on a single GPU again as a nod tort
efficiency and all three are really good
models
yeah the things that we've observed at
Electra
put them so like putting or texting to
some kind of representation space that
it's better than Bert and Roberta or is
it just like generally glue flies and
slightly better oh I like that question
and that could kind of cue up some
analysis work that you could do for a
final project because I think the
Insight behind your question is that a
lot of the time we reason about these
models just based on their performance
on something like blue you could ask a
deeper question what are their internal
representations like and are there
places where they're transformatively
better or worse and that you could tie
back that back to the fact that the
learning objective is different right
we're doing this discrimination thing as
opposed to filling in the blanks in some
sense maybe there are some underlying
differences I love that
all right couple more topics here just
quickly because we're going to do more
work with seek to seek models later
we're going to train some of our own
from scratch and you all might use some
fine-tuned ones and so I thought it
would be good to just get them on the
table as well
seek to seek here's some natural tasks
that fall into the seek to seek
structure machine translation right
Source language to target language
summarization big text to hopefully
smaller texts
freeform question answering where you go
from a question and then maybe you're
generating as opposed to just extracting
an answer
dialogue of course semantic parsing this
is the one we're going to tackle where
you go from a sentence to some kind of
logical form representing its meaning
code generation of course that's similar
and on and on I think there are lots of
problems that are pretty naturally cast
as seek to seek problems especially when
you've got kind of different stuff on
the input and the output side
yeah and the more General class of
things we could be talking about would
be encode or decoder where that's just
more General in the sense that at that
point the input could be a picture
you're encoding in the output a text
picture to picture video to picture in
principle anything could be happening on
the two sides and seek to seek would for
me just be the special case where we're
looking at sequential data typically
language data or computer code or
something
from the RNN ERA this is just kind of
nice if you hearken back to that era if
you live through it this is a paper from
Tang luang uh doing seek to seek on the
left in the traditional way with a
recurrent neural network an RNN pretty
simple right we've got a b c d coming in
and then it transitions into maybe other
parameters and it's trying to produce
this new sequence left to right coming
out
and just to remind you this is part of
the journey the field went on what Tong
did very influentially is think a lot
about how you would add attention layers
in
to that RNN that's what you see depicted
here this is a kind of schematic diagram
hinting at the fact that we were moving
into an era the vasuania all era
attention is all you need where
basically that attention layer would do
all the work
and that's kind of where we're at now
four seek to seek problems in general
this is a nice framework from the T5
paper there are a few different ways you
could think about them on the left is
the one I'm nudging you toward where we
have an encoder and a decoder and if
we're talking about Transformer models
what essentially that means is that when
we do encoding we can connect everything
to everything else and you can think of
that as a process of simultaneously
encoding the entire input with all its
connections but as we do decoding for
many of these problems we need to do
some kind of sequential generation and
the result of that is we can look back
to the decoder sorry the encoder all we
want but for the decoder we have to do
that masking that I described with the
auto regressive loss last time so that
we don't look into the future
but with that constraint we can do this
encoder decoder thing with a decoding
step be truly sequential decoding
but that's not the only way to think
about these problems and in fact I don't
want to presuppose that for a sequence
to sequence thing you'll use a sequence
to sequence model you could for example
use a language model and the way you
might do that is to say I'm just going
to encode everything left to right
that's the version in the middle
and then a kind of compromise position
would be that you would take your
language model which might be Auto
regressive but simultaneously encode the
entire input
and then begin your process of decoding
without explicitly having an encoder
part and a decoder part
I think all of them are on the table and
people are solving seek to seek tasks
right now using all of these variants
T5 I'm going to show you two uh there
are lots out there but these are very
prominent ones that you might download
so T5 this is a wonderful very rich
paper that does a lot of exploration of
which of these architectures are
effective and T5 ended up on an encoder
decoder variant and what they did is an
impressive amount of multitask training
unsupervised and supervised objectives
and an Innovative thing that they did is
have these task prefixes like translate
English to German and then an English
sentence or this is a cola sentence
that's just a data set people use or an
stsb sentence and that's the model's Q
to take that input and kind of condition
it very informally on that task so that
the output behavior is the expected
Behavior
there are lots of T5 models that you can
download this is nice for development
because some of them are very small and
some of them are very very large and
more recently there are these flan
models which took a T5 architecture and
did a lot of reinforcement learning with
human feedback to even further
specialize them to different tasks in
interesting ways
so that's T5 and then the other one that
you often hear about that's very
effective is Bart then Bart is
interestingly different yet again
so Bart is an encoder decoder framework
and it's really got kind of a Bert style
thing on the left and then a GPT style
thing on the right that is join encoding
of everything and then that auto
regressive part if you want to do
sequential generation
the Innovative thing about bart is that
the training involves a lot of
corrupting of that input sequence they
tried to like do text infilling of
pieces they shuffled sentences around
they did some masking they did some
token deletion rotating of documents all
of this corrupting of the input and then
the model's objective is to learn how to
essentially uncorrupt what it got as the
input they found that the joint process
of this text infilling thing and
sentence shuffling was the most
effective for training Bart
so that was for the pre-training phase
and when then you then when you
fine-tune with Bart for classification
tasks you just put in two uncorrupted
copies of your sentence and then you
could fit your task specific labels on
like the class token or the final token
of the GPT output and for seek to seek
you just use it as a standard encoder
decoder and again the intuition is that
the pre-training phase which did all
this corruption has helped the model
learn what sequences are like and that
blends together for me a lot of the
intuitions we've seen from MLM and from
what we just talked about with Elektra
yeah
a question that I asked last week these
models worked with like
spelling mistakes yeah so Bart is a
really good option if you want to do
spelling Corrections and I actually
think that that might be because
spelling correction is kind of as a test
a corrupting of the input where you're
trying to learn the uncorrupted version
of the output so I think if you want to
do grammar correction spelling
correction things like that it's
outstanding to use Bart and you might
just think of training from scratch on a
Model that you know is going to be aware
of characters for these character level
things
that was where they like
removed parts of the text essentially
and added other pieces to corrupt it
yeah where you just that's more like the
Bert style thing where you hide some
yeah
okay
punch you all to know about distillation
again because the theme of this course
could be how can we do more with less
and distillation is a vision for how we
could do more with less right we saw
this trend in model sizes here where
they're getting bigger and bigger and
there is some hope that they might now
be getting smaller
but we should all be pushing to make
them ever smaller and one way to think
about doing that is distillation and the
metaphor here is that we're going to
have two models maybe a really big
teacher model that was trained in a very
expensive way and might run only on a
supercomputer and then a much smaller
student
and we're going to train that student to
mimic the behavior of the teacher and we
could do that by just observing the
output behavior of the teacher and then
trying to get the student to align at
the level of the output and that would
basically just be treating this teacher
as a kind of input output device
we could also though think about
aligning the internal representations of
these two to get a deeper alignment
between teacher and student
here are some objectives in fact and
this is from least to most heavy duty
and you could combine them so we could
just use our gold data for the task I
put that as Step Zero because you might
want it in the mix here even as you use
your teacher we could also learn just
from the teacher's output labels
that's a bit of a funny idea but I think
the intuition is that the teacher might
be doing some very complicated
regularization that helps the student
learn more efficiently so even if there
are mistakes in the teacher's Behavior
the student actually benefits
you could also think about going one
level deeper and using the full output
scores like the logits so not just the
discrete outputs but the whole
distribution that the model predicts and
that's what they did in one of the
original distillation papers
you could also tie together the final
output States if the two models have the
same layer-wise dimensionality then for
example in this distilbert paper they
enforce as part of the objective a
cosine similarity between the output
states of teacher and student and now
you need to have access to the model
itself and this will be much more
expensive because you need to run the
teacher as part of distillation
you could also think about doing this
with lots of other hidden States people
have explored lots of other things and
you could even this is a paper that we
did try to mimic them under different
counterfactuals where you kind of change
around the input representations of the
teacher observe the output and then try
to get the student to do that to mimic
very strange behavior from the teacher
and then there are a bunch of other
things you can do so standard
distillation is where you have your big
model Frozen and the teacher is being
updated by the process you can have
multi-teacher that's where there are
lots of big models maybe doing multiple
tasks and you try to distill them all at
once down into a student that's a very
exciting New Frontier
co-distellation is where they're trained
jointly sometimes also called online
distillation that's where both the
teacher and the student are learning
together simultaneously might be
unnerving in the classroom but effective
for a model
and then self-destylation is actually
where you try to get like usually lower
parts of the model to be like other
parts of the model by having them mimic
themselves as part of the core model
training so that's a special case I
guess of code distillation where there's
only one model and you're trying to
distill parts of it into other parts
that's kind of wild to think about
and this has been applied in many
domains and the reason I can be
encouraging about this is that as we get
better and better at distillation we're
finding that distilled models are as
good or better than the teacher models
maybe for a fraction of the cost and
this is especially relevant if the model
is being used in production on a small
device or something so here are just
some glue performance numbers that show
across a bunch of these different papers
that with distillation you can still get
glue performance like the teacher with a
tiny model
yeah
just trying the simple model or is it
just that the teacher has access some
point of learning that is easier to
navigate through for a student but not
for a student you can do they know
I think something like what you just
said has to be right
I actually don't you so you're asking
about the special case where the teacher
just does its input output thing and
produces a data set that we train the
student on right and you're asking why
is that better than just training the
student on your original data it's very
mysterious to me
um I I the the best metaphor I can give
you is that it is a kind of regularizer
so the teacher is doing something very
complicated and even its mistakes are
useful for the student
I'm not worried about I like that it's a
beautiful opening line of a paper we
need to make it substantive by actually
explaining what that means but it's a I
like it as a vision for sure
I want to be a little careful of time
one more question and then I'll just
wrap up
balance we are the student is less less
General versus versus
the teacher
student yeah
I don't know I mean you would guess less
if it has a tiny capacity it won't have
as much of a capacity to overfit than
the teacher and maybe that's why in some
situations the students outperform the
teachers
I hope that's inspiring to you all let
me wrap up here
so you can go on to outperform me
architectures I didn't mention
Transformer XL wonderful creative
attempt to model long sequences by
essentially creating a recurrent process
across cached versions of earlier parts
of the long document you're processing
this is a beautiful and creative attempt
to use mask language modeling sorry an
auto regressive language modeling
objective but still have bi-directional
context and they do this by creating all
these permutation orders of the original
sequence so that you can effectively
condition on the left and the right even
though you can't look into the future
and then duberta this is really cool I
regret not fitting this in duberta is an
attempt to separate out the word and
positional encodings for these models
and kind of make the word embeddings
more like first-class citizens and
that's very intuitive for me because
that's like showing that we want the
model to learn some semantics for these
things that separate from their position
and they did that by reorganizing the
attention mechanisms
the known limitations we did a good job
on these except for this final one bird
assumes that the predicted tokens are
all independent of each other given the
unmasked tokens they gave you that
example of masking new and York and it
thinking that both of those are
independent of the other given that the
surrounding context Excel net again
addresses that and that might be
something that you want to meditate on
pre-training data here's a whole mess of
resources if you did want to pre-train
your own model maybe Sid we'll talk more
about this I'm offering these primarily
because I think you might want to audit
them as You observe strange behavior
from your large models the data might be
the key to figuring out where that
behavior came from
and then finally current trends right
Auto regressive architecture seem to
have taken over but that could be just
because everyone is so focused on
generation I have an intuition that
models like Bert are still better if you
just want to represent examples as
opposed to doing generation
seek to seek is still a dominant choice
for tasks with that structure although
again point one might be pushing
everyone to just use GPT 3 or 4 even for
models with seek to seek structure we'll
see how that plays out and then people
are still obsessed with scaling up but
we might be seeing a counter movement
towards smaller models especially with
reinforcement learning with human
feedback and that's something that we're
going to talk about next week and the
week after
so I kind of
restructured a little bit of my talk so
like we're only getting through like
part one today which is actually Back to
Basics how Transformers work and then
we're going to talk about the other
stuff
um I should maybe introduce myself
I'm Sid I am a fourth year PhD I
actually work primarily on language for
Robotics and kind of channeling one of
the Core Concepts of the class it's all
about doing
a whole lot with very very little like
I'm really just working on how we get
robots to follow instructions given just
like one example of a human you know
opening a fridge or you know pouring
coffee
things like that
um but in kind of doing that research it
became really really clear that we
needed better raw materials better
starting points so I started working on
pre-training first in language and then
more recently in Vision Video and
Robotics with language kind of as the
central theme
so I want to talk today about fantastic
language models and how to build them
so Richard Feynman is you know probably
not only one of the greatest physicists
of all time but he's one of the greatest
educators of all time one of the
greatest science educators
um and here's this quote
um you know what I cannot create I do
not understand and for him it was really
just kind of about building blocks how
do I understand what is going on at the
lowest level so I can compose them
together and figure out what to do next
where is the next Innovation where does
the next Discovery come from
and so kind of with that in mind I
actually just want to spend the next 12
or so minutes talking about building
language models building Transformers
and how that all happened
so it's a practical take on these
large-scale language models we're
probably not going to get to the large
scale bit
um and we're gonna get to the full
pipeline again we're only going to focus
on the model architecture but today the
evolution of the Transformer how we got
there
um training at scale we'll probably
cover some other time
um and then we'll talk about like you
know very very briefly efficient
fine-tuning an inference and we have
some other great cities that might
actually be talking about this more in
depth
um but the punch line is uh the last few
years like I started my PhD in 2019
um I trained my first you know deep
learning mnist model in 2018 feels
changed a lot since then and with every
new model with every new GPT uh one two
three four the five that's trading right
now
um there's been more and more folk
knowledge things that are hidden from
plain sight that we never get to see and
it's been the job of people like us
students people in Academia to kind of
ReDiscover find the insights find the
intuition Behind these ideas
and kind of rediscovering those
pipelines it's actually
our comparative advantage and figuring
out okay so these are how these pieces
came to be what do I do next
um and so I don't really care about time
uh if we get through five slides that is
a success for me
um but be selfish like this is your
class so you have any questions if I say
anything you don't understand that's the
contract call me out ask a question and
we're just going to kind of go step by
step
so how did we get to the Transformer
right how did this become the Bedrock of
language modeling and now you know
Vision also video also robotics for some
reason as of late how did we get here
so what is the recipe for a good
language model we've talked a bit about
contextual representations Chris was
talking through kind of the various you
know different you know phase changes
and language modeling history least of
segment diffusion language models which
is a completely different perspective
um I'm gonna kind of simplify things
oversimplify things like two steps
I need massive amounts of cheap easy to
acquire data we're a language modeling
we're building these contextual
representations because we want to learn
patterns we want to learn truths about
the world from data at scale and to do
that at scale we need data at scale so
that's one component
and the other is we need a simple and
high throughput way to consume it so
what does that mean
um
we need to be able to chew through all
of this data as fast as we possibly can
in the least opinionated way to figure
out you know all of the possible
patterns all the possible things that
could be useful for people fine-tuning
generating using these models for
arbitrary things Downstream
straight uh this isn't just a typical
language it's applicable to pretty much
everything the vision does this video
does this video and language video a
vision and language language and
Robotics all of them follow a similar
strategy
so right so simple in that it's natural
to scale the approach with data as we
get you know go from 300 billion to 600
billion tokens maybe make the model
bigger to handle that in a pretty simple
way the model should be composable in
general
um the training the way that we actually
ingest this data should be fast and
paralyzable and we should be you know
making the most of our Hardware if we're
going to run a data center with I don't
know 512 gpus with each eight GPU box
costing 120 000 I better be getting my
money's worth at the end of the day
um and the consumption part right like
this minimal assumptions on
relationships
the less opinionated I am about how
different parts of my dad is connected
the more I can learn given the first
thing massive amounts of data on sale
so kind of like figure out how we got to
the Transformer I want to kind of wine
time back to kind of well Christmas
alluding to earlier with arnetts right
so this is an RNN model kind of
complicated but it's from uh 224m I took
it literally from their slides I hope
John doesn't get mad at me
um
and
it's this very powerful class of model
in theory right I am ingesting arbitrary
lens sequences left to right and I'm
learning arbitrary patterns around them
people decided later on to you know add
these attention mechanisms on top of uh
the sequence of sequence RNN models to
figure out like how to kind of sharpen
their their focus as they are decoding
token by token right so the strengths
are like I get to handle arbitrary long
context and like we see kind of the
first semblance of attention appear kind
of very motivated by like the way we do
language translation right like when I'm
translating word by word there's certain
words in the input that are going to
matter I'm going to sharpen my focus too
but there are issues with rnns they're
not the most scalable at producing the
next token requires me to produce every
single token beforehand I can't really
make them deeper without training
stability going to Pieces so that's
rough
um and so chewing through a large amount
of data with an RNN is hard
some people refuse to believe that and
they've actually done immense work in
trying to scale up RNs make them more
paralyzable using lots and lots of
really cool linear algebra tricks I'll
post some links
um
and then separately uh kind of from the
vision community that kind of bled into
language Community we have convolutional
neural networks and this is from a other
course from Lena voita about using cnns
for language modeling and the idea here
is we have
um this ability to do immense deep
parallelizable training
um by kind of taking these like little
Windows right I'm going to look at you
know each layer is only going to look at
like the you know three word context at
a time and going to give me
representation but if I stack this
enough times and I have these residual
connections that combine you know
earlier inputs with later inputs by the
time I'm like 10 layers deep I've seen
everything in the window
but I need that depth and
that's kind of a drawback but they're
like really cool powerful ideas here and
I'd actually say that the Transformers
have way more to do with cnns and the
way that they behave than the way rnns
behave right so we have this idea of a
CNN layer kind of having multiple
filters multiple kernels different ways
of looking at and extracting features
from an image or features from text
you have you know the ability to kind of
scale depth using these residual
connections right the deepest networks
that we had you know from 2012 2015 even
now are still Vision models right resnet
151 isn't called 151 because it's you
know the 151st edition of the resnet
there's 151 because it's 151 layers deep
it's actually 151 blocks deep
um layers it's actually like probably 4X
that
um and it's paralyzable right every
little window that I see at every layer
can be computed completely independently
of every other layer which is really
really great for Modern Hardware modern
gpus
um so looking at this
seems like cnns are cool
um seems like rnns are cool there's a
natural question which is like how do
you do better
uh this is the picture from Christmas
lights that Lisa also used
um this is a very scary looking picture
right like what does self-attention mean
where do those ideas come from
so
one idea like one key component like the
one missing component for how you get
from the CNN and an RNN to a Transformer
is the idea that each individual token
is its own query key and value it's its
own entity that can be used to shape the
representations of all of the other
tokens
right so I'm going to turn this word uh
into its own querykin value I'm going to
use the attention from the rnns and I'm
going to use the depth parallelizability
scaling from the CNS
um and then the multi-headed part of
self-attention is exactly like what the
you know different convolutional filters
the different kernels are doing in a CNN
it's giving you different perspectives
on that same token different ways to
come up with queries different insights
into like how we can use you know a
single token and come up with multiple
different representations and fuse them
together
is it code
um code is semi-unimportant
um it's a very kind of very terse
description of like what multi-headed
self attention looks like
um Key Parts here are this you know
little bit where we kind of project an
input sequence of tokens to the queries
keys and values and then we're just
going to rearrange them um kind of in
some way uh and the important part here
is that like we are rearranging them in
a way that splits them into these
different views these different heads
where each head has some fixed Dimension
which is like the key dimension of the
Transformer
um and then we have these query keys and
values that we're then going to use for
this attention operation which comes
directly from the RNN literature right
it is really just this dot product
between queries and keys that is a very
complicated way of saying that's that's
a matrix multiply
um and then we're going to just project
them and
combine them back into our tensor of you
know batch size by sequence length by
embedding dimension
um caught me off at one point when you
look at these models like you download
verb and it says multi-headed attention
or whatever there's only one set of
Weights even though it's multi-headed uh
do you want to unpack that for us yeah
so
the convolutional kernel has kind of
this really nice way of expressing like
I have multiple resolutions of an image
right it's like that death channel of a
convolutional filter
um and if you kind of unpack like the
con 2D layer in pytorch you kind of see
that come out you don't really see that
here you see just like this one big
weight Matrix that is literally like
this you know dimensionality you know
embed Dimension by three times in bed
dimension is usually what it is in
Burger GPT
that three uh is the way you split into
query excuse and values
but we're actually going to kind of like
take that Vector that is like you know
embed dim size and just chunk it up into
each of these different filters right so
rather than make those filters explicit
as by providing them as a parameter that
Define some weight layer
for efficiency purposes we're actually
just going to treat it all as one Matrix
and then just chunk it up as we're doing
the linear algebra operations does that
make sense
queries keys and values and the number
of heads is further yeah so so one of
the kind of like the key rules that like
no one ever tells you about Transformers
is that your number of heads has to
evenly divide your Transformer hidden
Dimension that's usually a check that is
explicitly done in the code for training
like bird or GPT
um and usually the code doesn't work if
that doesn't happen and that's kind of
how you get away with a lot of these
efficiency tricks it's a great question
so we should do a whole course on
broadcasting yeah before you even start
this so that you can do this mess oh man
yeah and and uh there's a great
professor at Cornell Tech Sasha Rush who
kind of has like a bunch of like
tutorials just like basic like
broadcasting tensor operations it's
fantastic that you can check out there's
a question yeah can you just clarify
what you mean by chunking yeah so if I
have a vector of let's say length 1024
right that is my embedding Dimensions
the hidden dimension for my Transformer
and if I have keys of say Dimension uh
let's say two uh make it easy chunking
just means that I'm going to split that
Vector of 1024 into two heads each of
dimension 512.
right so I'm literally just going to
like reshape that vector
and chunk them up into like two views of
the same input
cool
um is this actually better is this alone
enough to define a Transformer
maybe if not all right answers no so
um it's good because like we get all the
parallelization advantages and all kind
of the attention advantages that I
talked about in the previous slide um
this is a slide from like Justin Johnson
and Doctor Who were both Stanford alums
now teaching courses about Transformers
and deep learning at various colleges
um but you're missing uh kind of like
one key component right so
if you just look at this and squint at
this for like a little bit of time uh
what you're missing is like okay so I am
just taking different weighted averages
of the same
underlying values over and over again
relative to the things that are coming
out of my Transformer there actually is
no non-linearity with just
self-attention
this is basically a glorified linear
Network
so we need some way to fix that because
that's where the express the exclusivity
the kind of the magic of deep learning
happens it's kind of when we stack these
non-linearities go deeper and learn new
patterns at scale
so
um
this is how we do it we had an MLP we
had an MLP to the very end of the
Transformer block and it's very simple
right and all it does is it kind of
takes the embedding Dimension that comes
out of the self-attention block that we
just defined
projects it to a higher dimensional
space
adds a rail a value on linearity and
then down projects back to the embedding
dimension usually what you're going to
see is a factor of four why is it a
factor of four no one knows is the
honest answer uh two didn't seem to work
well enough eight seemed to be too big
but here's some like
soft intuition for kind of why this
might work it's kind of is a throwback
to like two two nine you know ogml days
so
you want your network as a whole to be
able to kind of both forget the things
that are unimportant but also remember
the things that are important right
that's kind of the role so the
sharpening the remembering things that
are important are these residual
connections like the fact that I'm
adding X to some transform of x
the forgetting is what this MLP is doing
it's basically saying like what stuff
can I throw away and should I basically
forget because it's not really relevant
to what I care about at the end of the
day which are good contextual
representations
and so the role of the MLP is very
similar to the role of kind of a kernel
and you know the good old support Vector
machine literature right so if I have
two classes that are kind of like this
in a plane and I want to draw a line
that partitions them how do I do it
um well it's hard if I'm only working in
2D but with just a very simple learn
transform if I just you know implicitly
lift these things up to like 3D
I can turn this into a surface in 3D
that I can just cut in half separates my
stuff so projecting up with this MLP is
basically this way of kind of like
aligning or crystallizing the structure
of our features uh learning a good
decision battery in space
and compressing from there I think we're
out of time so we're going to go through
like the rest of the Transformer
evolution in a bit but uh all the slides
are up I have office hours tomorrow and
I will be back thanks